I'm just going to give you guys a brief
overview of what Jasmine is and
how we are going to be
using it in our project.
So I'm going to be screen
sharing right now.
>> Yep, there you go.
>> Okay,
as you can see I am in our
GitHub repo for feed reader.
So, whenever you go into,
you have this master branch where
you have a bunch of different
folders index.html, readme.
You go into Jasmine, and then you go
into spec where you see feedreader.js.
This is the file that you're going
to be writing your test soon in.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, as you can see,
this file only has some stuff in it.
So, it has a bunch of
documentation which is really good,
you guys have to go through it, since
all the tests that you will be writing
are listed under To-Dos, right here.
So let me just sort of, yeah.
Let me zoom into it.
Okay.
So you have all these To-Dos.
So all these To-Dos are the tests
that you need to be writing.
So about that, if you can see, there is
one little sort of code that is written.
And it's actually written
using Jasmine documentation.
So what they describe is
actually [INAUDIBLE] is it's
defining a suite, and the name of
the suite is going to be RSS feeds.
So, this is going to be the start of
your test suite for RSS feeds for
testing RSS feeds.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And then you have these
documents in here,
>> [COUGH]
>> That specifies this is our first
test and a test to make sure that all
feeds variable have been defined and
that it's not empty.
And you have to experiment
with this before you
get started with your project.
So what happens when you change allFeeds
and upload gs to be an empty area and
refresh the page?
As you can see, this is what Jonathan
was talking about in his last office
hours-
>> Mm-hm.
>> Where he actually deleted
the allFeeds variable, made it empty and
then he sort of tried running
this code and it failed.
So, what I'm going to do is,
the next part, line 24 is it,
our defined function.
So, what it is, is the it function
inside, is called a spec.
So, what is a spec?
A spec is a JavaScript function
that says what some piece
of your program should be doing.
So as you can see,
RSS feeds need to be defined.
That is essentially what you
have to do in this code.
And It is just a function that's
going to define your specs.
So, a test sweep can have a zillion
specs that define a zillion tests.
The next line when you go,
is the expect function.
So, what does the expect says?
So, the expect function acts on
the allFeeds variable and it says,
toBeDefined, so
you need all the feeds inside
your JSON object to be defined and
the length should not be zero.
So as you can,
see this is fairly readable.
And if you want to explore all these
functionalities, the toBeDefined and
toBeZero functionalities,
what you can do is you can go
back to the Jasmine folder, and
then go into the your Jasmine2.1.2.
And when you open Jasmine.js,
what you can see is,
I'm going to be searching toBeDefined.
So, as you can see,
there are four instances.
So, the first one is actually
providing you a matchers, so,
as you can see,
these are called matchers.
So, whatever goes into your expect, and
all these functions
are called your matchers.
So, you go down and you can see
that this is how the toBeDefined is
defined and
it's going to either return, I think,
a variable that is going to say,
no, is it true or is it false.
So that's what it's sort
of going to give you.
And you have a lot of other functions
called toBeFalse, toBeGreaterThan,
toBeLessThan.
You can make use of any of
these inside your test suite,
depending upon what sort of
tests you want to act on.
So yeah, that was a very quick and
short summary.
But if you have more questions on p6,
feel free to post on the forums.
And I'm sure your peers or the
instructors will be glad to help you.